[Musique]
ce qu'il manque aux côtés de sinon
j'aime bien un truc c'est de simplex des
complots gros je rap français en tout
cas j'ai validé il valide il ya plein
plein de gens que j'en oublie j'étais en
oublier de la com ça effectivement ça
rajoute un profond coma l'idée vous avez
vu qu'il s'agit c'est chris macari gros
les serrures soumet tous les noms des
gens qui apparaissent dans la série et
que tu fais une genre de mini step et
tous ces gens là pause la mixtape
c'est un classique d'eau pour la liste
des gens qui ont répondu présent ça va
deux des artistes qui sont plus de
l'ancienne génération mais qui sont
tellement ancrée est tellement des
grands artistes qui sont toujours
présents
new star ac le mans comme kool shen
busta flex cutkiller qui viennent et qui
te font confiance et qui sont contents
pour l'amour durable d'être dans ce
premier projet est bien mieux un ton
plein d'autres à pantin tonique et enfin
les freestyle tous battus et bravo merci
ça fait plaisir mais aussi d'avoir la
jeune génération comme comme niño convoi
tranquille qui est un mec qu'on voulait
absolument avoir parce que c'est un
phénomène s'est dit de loin des plus
talentueux de sa génération et à la
crise lui est venue directement via
instagram me dire wright fait une série
sur le rap pour ce qu'on n'est pas à mes
yeux on se parle on croise mac tyer
craquer une espèce de monuments tu vois
que les gens appellent le général dans
le milieu du rap soprano je voulais
juste te dire que j'étais derrière toi
qui lui incarne d'ailleurs dans la série
ce qu'on peut faire de plus grands avec
du rap français quoi c'est à dire
remplir des stades
incroyable d'un bon leurs frères grimm
cas il ya esprit noir howard rails on
peut voir géré chromé 12 la sexion
d'assaut avec mike on croiserait n'y
avait pas de grange qui fait aussi une
apparition
merci beaucoup on croise mystérieux et
appréhendent j'ai bien dit j'aime ce
côté clip qui leur disent ah non même
fait tourner à popeye
ça marque forcément cinq minutes ah ben
voilà un parfait pour paye cher un
régisseur son café tournée combat qui
fait tourner le soprano la révélation
rap de l'année à une fiche du bouscat ps
crise du demolition bienvenue dans la
nouvelle émission la nouvelle fera
driver qui très connu dans le milieu du
rap qui était rappeur qui est
chroniqueur sur rtl m allah au fret je
suis à l'antenne la dore direct comment
tu t'appelles red the sky galop rendre
ou non il ya du monde
bon flow mon texte bravo merci beaucoup
ce qui fait que valider et est attendu
c'est en grande partie grâce aux
rappeurs et à tous ces protagonistes du
milieu du rap qui ont validé cette série
et qui ont qui l'ont poussé parce que ça
c'était la clé de tout imagine bien que
si le milieu du rap avaient décidé de ne
pas cautionner cette série ça a été un
gros problème
un rappeur à partir du moment où il
vient sur la série il amène toute son
intégrité et son image sa sa crédibilité
et c'est pourquoi on a passé des heures
à discuter avec des rappeurs qui avait
un premier avis positif sur l'idée de
devenir avant la série mais qui met tout
simplement besoin de savoir ce qu'on
allait faire ce qu'on allait raconter et
c'était normal quoi
c'est normal qu'on les rassure
justement je voulais te proposer quelque
chose ce que je voulais avec chacun de
ses guez c'était que il apporte ce qu'il
représente
soprano lui va les aider à réchauffer un
espèce de d'image positive et c'est ce
que peut apporter soprano je vais faire
une grosse exclue avec une nouvelle
chanson et j'aimerais bien que tu viens
de poser un petit couplet tout ça la
crimée est contactée à un moment dans la
série parce qu'ils ont besoin de régler
un problème et qui va être très adapté à
ce que peut être la crème en fait quoi
si une tranquille poteau il est juste
venu fumer le chichon génie pour rigoler
un peu j'espère bien sûr je pars gaulle
est mort à bombay en fait la diversité
de ceux du hip hop français
j'ai essayé de l'incarner à travers les
guest à qui j'ai proposé de participer à
cette série qui tendent à valider une
création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal